[Musique]
les sénateurs
agissent colère des agriculteurs le
Sénat avait sonné l'alarme face à
l'ampleur de la protestation des
agriculteurs la commission des affaires
européennes s'est réunie ce jeudi 25
janvier l'occasion pour son président
Jean-François Rapin de rappeler les
mises en garde répété du Sénat sur
l'impact pour les agriculteurs de la
dernière réforme de la politique
agricole commune la PAC et de la
stratégie européenne dite de la ferme à
la
table le Sénat est à l'origine de quatre
résolutions européenne au cours des 7
dernières années pour demander un
renforcement de la politique agricole
commune depuis 2017 il a insisté sur la
sécurisation des revenus agricoles et
préconiser une gestion pragmatique des
enjeux
environnementaux de plus le Sénat a
demandé à ce que la PAC bénéficie à
minima d'un budget constant et soit
considéré comme une priorité stratégique
dont les objectifs priment sur ceux de
la politique de
concurrence en parallèle la commission
des affaires européennes a fait part de
ses inquiétudes dès la présentation en
2020 de la stratégie européenne appelée
de la ferme à la table qui constitue la
feuille de route de l'Union européenne
en matière d'agriculture et
d'alimentation alors que des études
prévoient une baisse de production de 10
à 20 % d'ici 2030 le Sénat a adopté le 6
mai 2022 une résolution européenne pour
revoir d'urgence cette stratégie afin de
privilégier la production agricole et
l'autonomie alimentaire de l'Union
européenne dans le contexte de la guerre
en Ukraine alors qu'un accord de libre
échange entre l'Union européenne et les
pays du Mercosur se précise
Jean-François rppin soulligne que près
de la moitié de l'empreinte carbone
alimentaire française est liée aux
importations de produits
agricoles la commission des affaires
européennes exhorte à nouveau la
Commission européenne à infléchir sa
politique agricole et à mettre fin à la
concurrence déloyale dont sont victimes
les
agriculteurs pour suivre ces travaux
rendez-vous sur le site internet du
Sénat
[Musique]